hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry
so today we're gonna check out a trailer
for one of my favorite characters in
history Lucifer Lucifer the official
trailer this guy has done so many things
he's been in so many movies books song
you gotta admit like yes he is evil but
he's good at doing what he does he's a
crafty badger he's a crafty badger
anyway this is a Fox show so we know
it's gonna be raw bloody and gritty
let's do this this is a person badass
people like to tell me things as the
dark naughty little desires are on their
mind you're not marrying this Human
Stain directly in love with him right
kind oh no oh my can't believe I just
said that let's be something about these
face
ah that was their pitch girl did I sell
my soul to the devil so the devil made
you do it did he the alcohol the drugs
the topless selfies and choices were you
my dear pull yourself together
hey witnesses Lucifer Morningstar is
that stage name god-given I'm afraid
don't you tell me something how did she
end up dying in a hailstorm of bullets
and you get away without a scratch the
benefits of immortality
what were your corrupt live an
organization do about is we're done here
somebody out there needs to be punished
stop caring you're the devil
I think you have a visitor that is ill
your return to the underworld has been
requested and just done Calendar here it
is the seventh of never through to the
15th ain't gonna happen now does that
work you guys try it
you think father's upset now he will not
be merciful for much longer we should be
out there punishing those responsible
come on I'll help you how could you
possibly help me I have the ability to
draw out people's forbidden desires
you're psychic or something no I can't
read people's minds mom Jedi
what is that sure okay you're thinking
about it aren't you do you two know each
other
no but I know that look so I wouldn't
recommend it I'm like walking heroine
very habit-forming it never ends well I
do yoga hot yoga look you did hurt you
what exactly do you think happens when
the devil leaves hell all of those
demons all of those tormented and
tortured souls where do you think they
go you some only immune to my charms
refer you to them as charms I think is a
bit of a stretch did my father send you
what's your name Lucifer exactly all
right here we go jer-bear time to review
this [ __ ] my thoughts have been formed
please do that every day every time we
have to do a review positives let's talk
about some positives maybe it's got a
snappy tone I have a charming
it looks like the humor is funny like
the humor could work as cool humor and I
like the guy who's playing the devil
he seems very charming in the devilish
kind of way there's a lot of charisma
you know it's like it's traditional and
why what other kind of devil would I
care to watch other than one who was
that deviant you know yeah this is the
kind of devil you put on a [ __ ] show
negatives it's on a Fox show which
hinders the aspects of hellish powers a
lot um yeah I mean like I get what
they're gonna do like you know well
their time can't get crazy with it but
you could be tv-14 lecherous and destroy
lots of things yeah but would it really
be so appealing when it's so obviously
cut back maybe to the target audience it
would be we gotta think like the devil
stuff we'll deal a lot with murder and
lust but you can do all that on these
shows you just can't show like you can't
you know give graphic images but like
people be [ __ ] all the time on yuusha
I know but it's all about the graphic
images I don't know I like no epic
images I'm sure you do
True Blood would have sucked if it was
on Fox it could definitely work like I
finally started watching arrow I was
like you know man this is a network show
but it's [ __ ] violent it's gritty and
it works and it doesn't need to be some
hard our show and maybe it could work
the Lucifer but I think you're dealing
with something like you got so many
other worlds you can go with but it
looks like they're going for just a fun
kind of
action/adventure ride yeah what I'm
going for the kind of show that works on
Fox what didn't work for me was when it
was getting all serious yeah it seems
like it's kind of having a little issues
fused about what the tones yeah but I
guess all these shows have moments where
they're like we're gonna be dramatic I
bet I bet you whoever sold this [ __ ]
out line was like what if the devil quit
his job and move to the City of Angels
yeah pitch done it's done we can see
that on posters and commercial contract
let's all you need a sell show that was
a tagline it doesn't have to be anything
of what the original script was yeah
yeah it's such a marketing thing yeah I
mean at the end of the day it looks like
it'll just be like some fun show again
if I start watching the show or if
people love it
I feel like it's going to be down to the
main actor of why people really like it
although it's the writer Californication
one of the writers I think that that
adds a lot of credibility to it because
he knows how to write dialogue well so
that's why I noticed in the humor was
the fun dialogue yeah do get characters
though this seems like it has the kind
of rhythm the kind of humor and the kind
of production value that works for
network it's not like when they try to
do the Playboy Club where it's like this
is about Playboy and some network TV I
genuinely think that the show is
probably better than what the trailer is
I think it's a poorly cut rate like it
starts off where it's you know oh the
devil is this humorous guy who likes to
[ __ ] with human beings and then some
woman gets shot and it's like no this is
a serious kind of crime drama show and
is he gonna rock a room or some devil
dude shows up and he's like hey you
supposed to be in Hell right Allen yeah
I'm like wait what kind of show is this
exactly yeah yeah I think that's gonna
be the number one kink or maybe it's
just ill represented by the yeah I'm
sure it'll be blended better in the
actual execution than how the trailer
was trying to convey all these different
things yeah and I mean it it doesn't
seem impossible it's like I've seen
better trailers and I've also seen worse
trailers like it looks fun I'm airing on
the side of like yeah mica no show
anything with the devil's usually
interesting I'm bedazzled
no totally but that was the best
portrayal of the devil I've ever seen a
little Nicky little Nicky
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects can you
can check out Jerry's playlist on the
channel reasons - Jerry has a lot of fun
movie reviews on there and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we get product placement for things such
as water drugs water jugs are great have
you know what they hold water you could
put it in the fridge cool it down and
when you're trying to get your
girlfriend pregnant what you can do is
fill this up with semen as much semen as
possible you got to think you know you
how many sperm how much 24 just like 300
million something like that now what if
you could like 10 times those odds
oh and then you just pour it into chorus
even I'm disgusted by my own joke right